Okay, since we changed
the data model around,
we're going to need to
do some refactoring.
Let's see what classes
we're going to touch.
This is a pretty big change in the way
that we're thinking about our data, so
I'm going to try to divide
up these changes into steps.
The first step is to
delete old constants.
I'm going to be here in
the Constants class.
You're going to remove
the whole active list node and
as such, there's some constants that
you're going to no longer need.
If you move these constants you can
easily see the places in your code that
were getting data from
the old active list location.
There's one here,
which is just the word active lists
that was being appended to your URLs.
And then down here,
in the URL constants, we also have
a constant that we can remove.
Okay, and now when you run
your code you're going to get
a lot of errors from the different
places that we're using these constants.
You can go through those errors or
if you really squeamish
about breaking your app.
You can right click or
use the keyboard shortcut and
use the Find Usages command.
Okay, let's go to the next step.
The next step is fixing up
the read operations and
this should be fairly quick.
You should think about
the screens again, and
which parts we'll need to read for
the new data location.
For example, all of this is list data,
it probably needs to read
from the new data location.
And this list name over here,
also list data, probably needs to
read from the new list location.
Updating writing will be
a bit more difficult.
Remember, whenever you change some
detail about the shopping list,
other than the items, it's going to
need to change in multiple places now.
It'll need to change in
the owner's shopping list and
in the shopping list of all the users
that the owner has shared the list with.
So I have a couple of thoughts of
the best way to approach this.
See if you remember a discussion
about using updateChildren?
Not sure when we had it, but basically,
updateChildren is preferable to set
value because it allows you to update
a bunch of different places
a good database all at once.
And therefore, you don't need to
worry about consistency issues.
Now that we've got a bunch of shopping
lists that we want to keep in sync,
it'll be even more important
to use updateChildren.
This will keep you from getting
into inconsistent half baked state,
where some users have updated lists and
others don't.
You might also remember that I talked
about making a helper method, and
this method is specifically for keeping
copies of the same object synced.
And this helper method
would be specifically for
updating a property of a shopping
list in multiple places.
The method could take information
about the shopping list and
the property to update.
And then, make that update to the
appropriate locations throughout your
app using key value pairs in a hash map.
When you're generating this hash map for
using updateChildren, remember that
every list is going to have an owner and
eventually they'll all
have a shared with a list.
We haven't implemented sharing yet, so
right now just focus on the code
to update the owner of the list.
It seems a little silly because you're
using updateChildren to only update one
property but I'll make the switch
to using shared with a lot easier.
Whenever and
wherever you change a property for
a shopping list, you should be using
this method that you just made.
Okay, so here are all the thoughts
I have about the refactor and
I've also included the finalized
database schema the notes again.
Why don't you take a look at
the spec and then update the out.
Thanks a bunch.